do you understand  why your customers are angry now they're  being asked to make restrictions yet you  guys are leaking lots of water yes i  mean our customers pay for our water  they expect to get water when they need  it for whatever they want to use it for  and i do completely understand that  so i do think they understand that in  these unprecedented times it makes sense  to ask people to just you know dial down  that non-essential usage put the hose  pipes away the difficult thing about  drought is you know when you go into a  drought you don't know when you're  coming out  the forecast does show  little or no rain for the foreseeable  future that's not a good position if we  go through another dry winter we are  going to see a prolonged period of water  shortage and the drought is going to go  on